know that title is not a typo we are not
talking about the infamous ripper who
preyed on the working girls of white
chapel in victorian london
we've already done that a while back so
if you want to learn about him maybe go
give that video a watch instead today
we're talking about a lesser-known
killer who was responsible for the
so-called
hammersmith nude murders of the 1960s
like the ripper he targeted prostitutes
but he had a tendency to rip their
clothes off during the killings with
these two things his name became
immediately obvious to every
self-respecting tabloid journalist in
the country
london was being terrorized by jack the
stripper
story begins on the morning of june 17
1959 on the banks of the river thames in
the chiswick district of west london a
park by the river called duke's meadows
had a reputation being a lover's lane
where young couples would retreat for a
bit of private time it was also a
popular spot for prostitution as many
working girls took their clients there
earning the parks the
much more vulgar nickname of gobblers
gulch
policemen who patrolled that area were
used to seeing a lot of unusual stuff
but
even they were taken completely aback by
what they discovered that morning it was
the body of a young woman dumped near
the towpath near the river she was
left propped up against a tree with her
dress torn open and strangulation marks
on her throat
her shoes and underwear were missing
after circulating a photograph of the
victim police soon had a name
twenty-one-year-old elizabeth figg
although she had been previously
arrested under the name ann phillips
her story was a sad but familiar one
after her mother kicked her out of the
house she started hanging out with the
wrong people and soon turned to
prostitution to make ends meet
police opened an investigation but
couldn't find a lot to go on as the
killer did not leave any clues behind
the landlord of a nearby pub called the
ship claimed that he and his wife saw a
car parked in the area but again this
was not out of the ordinary for duke's
meadows he also said that the car turned
off its headlights shortly after
midnight
and that he then heard a woman scream
but had no desire to explore any further
at first the authorities were hopeful
that they might have an easy arrest on
their hands spigg's boyfriend at the
time was a man named fenton ward who was
also her pimp and had a violent streak
in him however they ultimately dismissed
him as a suspect during the
investigation eventually
police concluded that elizabeth figg was
killed by one of her clients
most likely in his own car but never
really made any more progress than that
since they didn't really consider the
death of a cool girl to be a priority
and
because nobody yet knew this was
probably the start of a serial killing
spree the murder of elizabeth figg soon
faded from memory
for years until the killer struck again
even today the exact number of victims
ascribed to jack the stripper is in
doubt but
it usually ranges between six and eight
some consider that elizabeth figg may
have been murdered by a different person
because
there was a long pause between her death
and the others over four years had
passed until police had another body on
their hands
it was november the 8th 1963 and workers
at a refuse disposal site in morton lake
stumbled upon the corpse of a young
woman who had been buried in a shallow
grave the dump site was located on the
other side of the river thames about a
mile away from the previous crime scene
also near the towpath
this time the body was completely naked
except for a single stocking but a
post-mortem examination showed that the
woman once again
had strangulation marks but she also had
some missing teeth
although it was the most likely scenario
the medical examiner could not say
definitively
that she had been strangled because the
remains were too decomposed the new
victim was soon identified as
22-year-old gwyneth reese from south
wales her story was very familiar to
that of elizabeth figg she
didn't get along with her family so
eventually she left the small town life
behind and moved to london
with naive hopes of making it big in the
city unfortunately she didn't make it
she met the wrong kind of people and
left with little choice for money she
soon started working as a prostitute
like in the case of elizabeth figg
police initially suspected reese's pimp
since he
was known to be a violent man his name
was connie whitehead and he was a member
of the firm
the notorious mobster group led by the
kraytwins however authorities could not
connect him to the crime
afterwards they considered the
possibility that reese had died during a
botched abortion
they knew that she had become pregnant
that summer a common problem for cool
girls since contraceptives were still
hard to come by
abortions were illegal so women like
gwyneth ries had no choice but to turn
to shady amateurs who performed back
alley medical procedures that
came with a lot of potential dangers but
if this was the real cause of death
why strangle her and then dump her naked
body in a shallow grave where she was
certain to be discovered just like in
the previous case these are questions
that have remained unanswered
at the time nobody connected the deaths
of the two women together and even today
some do not consider either fig or reese
to be
victims of jack the stripper presumably
it is because there were a lot more
similarities between the six murders
that followed and also because they all
occurred within a much shorter frame of
time of
almost exactly one year in the minds of
many the killing spree of jack this
tripper started on february
2 1964 with the discovery of hannah
taylford
her body was found by rowers on the
thames located on the shore next to
hammersmith bridge the 30 year old woman
had been
in the water for several days having
last been seen on january 24th just like
winter threes talford was found
completely naked except for some rolled
down stockings
she also had teeth missing and her
underwear had been forced down her
throat
however there was a significant
difference between her and the other
women even though talford had
strangulation marks on her neck a
postmortem examination revealed that she
died
by drowning suggesting that she may have
been choked unconscious and then thrown
in the river while she was still alive
predictably her tail was just as sad and
tragic as the previous victims born in
lancashire into a mining family hannah
taylford was considered a problem child
who got expelled from several schools
she eventually ran away from home as a
teenager and made her way to london
where she quickly began amassing
convictions for theft and soliciting at
one point
it was reported that she even tried
selling her unborn baby through the
classified ads
there have been quite a few sensational
stories about hannah taylford and
while it is hard to say which ones are
true it would certainly seem that she
wasn't your average cool girl she told
friends that on several occasions she
had been paid to attend wild sex parties
at lavish mansions belonging to
london's upper classes in one notable
instance talford said that she was
picked up by limousine and
brought to a house where she had sex
with a man dressed in a gorilla costume
as a crowd of onlookers surrounded them
and cheered given these stories police
investigated the possibility that hannah
taylford was silenced because she knew
too much about the powerful elite of
england it was an alluring idea but it
didn't go anywhere and shockingly enough
not even the press pounced on the
opportunity it seems like
more so than the police they were
willing to admit that there might be a
maniac preying on cool girls in
hammersmith the next victim was found
just two months later on april the 8th
again
on the foreshore of the thames just a
few hundred yards away from the spot
where hannah taylford was discovered
she was also naked and had ligature
marks on her neck although like the
previous woman it appeared that the
actual cause of death was drowning she
was 26 years old and was either pregnant
at the time of her death or
had recently visited an illicit
abortionist to obtain a treatment
her name was irene lockwood and her
story was unsurprisingly
similar to the other women she came to
london when she was younger and resorted
to prostitution as a means of making a
living
however police heard rumors that
lockwood was often in the habit of
scamming her clients sometimes by
having male friends of hers rob them and
other times by taking photographs and
blackmailing them this would have
certainly increased the pool of suspects
who may have wanted her dead but
something unexpected
happened later that same month on april
27th a 57 year old man named kenneth
archibald
entered nottingham police station and
confessed to killing irene lockwood
archibald worked as a caretaker at a
tennis club with a shady reputation of
staging after-hours parties full of
booze drugs and sex
prostitutes such as irene lockwood were
known to frequent such gatherings
looking for clients and
indeed police had already questioned
archibald after finding his business
card in her apartment
at first it would seem like they would
be able to put this case to bed besides
his confession archibald also knew to
take investigators to the pub where
lockwood had last been seen alive and
afterwards showed them the place where
he strangled her ostensibly due to a
fight over money
following that he stripped her naked
throw in the river and then burnt her
clothes at home
unsurprisingly kenneth archibald was
arrested and put in jail awaiting trial
however while police were building their
case against him it seemed they were
unable to find
any other piece of evidence connecting
him to the crime or rather
crimes as by this point they were fairly
convinced that at least two of the
murders
had been committed by the same person
they couldn't do it all they had was
archibald's own statement
and by the time his trial came around in
june he retracted his confession saying
that he was depressed and
drunk when he made it this was just as
well as investigators were never really
truly convinced that
the tiny elderly half-death caretaker
was the culprit so archibald was
acquitted
and the hunt for the killer continued
even before kenneth archibald came
forward police already had another
murder on their hands
just two weeks after the death of irene
lockwood the body of 22 year old helen
barthelme was
found in an alley in brentford even
though she had not been dumped near the
thames like the other victims police had
little doubt that she had been killed by
the same person since
the rest of the circumstances were
almost identical bartholmy was a
prostitute she was found naked with
ligature barks on her neck and she had
missing teeth and bruises on her face
suggesting that she had been hit as with
irene lockwood there was the possibility
that barcelona
might have made some enemies she had
previously served some time in blackpool
for aggravated burglary after luring a
client to a secluded area and
having him robbed by her friends if she
continued committing such acts after
moving to london
it wouldn't have been out of the
question that she pissed off the wrong
person
however police thought this unlikely at
this point a clear pattern emerged and
there was little doubt in their minds
that a serial killer was stalking the
streets of london
strangely enough the fact that barcelona
was dumped in an alleyway ended up being
the most significant part of her murder
because her body hadn't been found in
the water police had their first solid
lead
in the case tiny specks of paint were
left on her skin
a bit of research revealed that this was
the kind of paint used in automatic
spray painting of cars and
other metal work which was done in
special storage containers because
otherwise the paint particles would
penetrate through regular walls jack the
stripper could have been a painter or at
the very least
have access to such a storage container
where he could keep body
after the death of hell and barcelona
london police stepped up their efforts
the investigation was taken over by the
commander of scotland yard's criminal
investigation department or cid
george hatharill he made an unusual move
for that time and put out a public
warning to the city's prostitutes
alerting them that there was a madman
among them and
pleading with them to come forward with
any leads under the promise of absolute
secrecy
meanwhile patrolmen were instructed to
write down the license plates of all the
cars they encountered in the area after
dark while
female officers went undercover as
prostitutes in the hopes that they might
run into the killer consequently dozens
of women came forward with information
but this proved to be in vain as
jack the stripper struck again in july
the victim was 30-year-old mary fleming
from scotland whose naked body was found
in a quiet residential area in chiswick
on the morning of july the 14th this
time
there were clear signs of a struggle
mary fleming put up a fight and had
bruises on her body from being punched
repeatedly once again flecks of paint
were found on her skin
however the element that attracted
investigators attention was the place
where the body was dumped
like with helen barcelony the killer
avoided his usual dumping grounds near
the thames but
there was a significant difference
between the two locations bartheley's
body was
left in a dark secluded alleyway most
likely to avoid the
increased police scrutiny around the
thames mary fleming on the other hand
was dumped in a very busy public place
with a heavy police presence which
the authorities saw as a taunt at their
expense several neighbors heard a car
reversing down the street shortly before
fleming's body was found
unfortunately because it was still very
early in the morning none of them got up
to look
once again jack the stripper had eluded
capture but there was a feeling that he
was getting more arrogant
it was more likely that he would make a
mistake that could ultimately
lead to his arrest
by this point jack the stripper was a
popular subject in the british media
cool girls began
taking whatever precautions they could
some carried knives with them others
worked in pairs and
made sure to look at each other's
clients this still proved to be
useless because a few months later the
killer struck again on the night of
october the 23rd 21 year old scottish
native francis brown and her friend kim
taylor went to a pub in notting hill to
have a drink before heading out for work
both women were prostitutes and they
even teased each other that they would
become the stripper's next victim
for francis brown who sometimes went by
margaret mcgowan this terrifying
scenario became reality
she disappeared that night and went
missing for over a month before her body
was found on november 25th
dumped in an alley in kensington all the
hallmarks of jack the stripper were
present
the body was naked the woman had been
strangled and there were paint flecks on
her skin again it was sad that another
person had to die
but police were confident that the
killer finally made that fatal mistake
that they were waiting for he left a
witness kim taylor the friend of that
last victim saw the client that francis
brown left with on the night of her
disappearance
she recognized his car as being either a
ford zephyr or a ford zodiac but
more importantly she saw his face taylor
sat down with an identicate and produced
a sketch for the police
with these two new major clues
authorities believe that identifying the
killer was only a matter of time
and yet the year ended with no suspects
1965 started with a new development but
it wasn't the kind of development the
police were hoping for
it was a new body jack the stripper's
last known victim was a 28 year old
irish immigrant named bridget o'hara
known as bridgey she went missing on
january 11th and was found over a month
later on february the 16th
dumped behind a storage shed in acton
pretty close to where mary fleming had
been found
once again the common elements were
there the body was naked cause of death
was strangulation
the victim had some missing teeth and
there were traces of paint on the skin
there was a promising new lead though
after finding so many victims with those
strange flecks of paint on them
police were finally able to match them
to some paint on the bottom of a
transformer
located at the back of a building on the
heron trading estate opposite of that
building was a paint spray shop which
confirmed some of their earlier
suspicions this meant that the killer
used that building to store some of his
victims but
here's the strange part the reason the
police found it was because jack the
stripper left the body of a hara just a
few dozen yards from the transformer he
led investigators straight to his
hideout
more or less why would he do that did he
just get lazy or perhaps deep down did
he want to get caught
unlikely was he planning on moving the
body later or was this another taunt
of the police revealing the killer's
uncontrollable arrogance
while the investigation was ongoing
police talked to the press claiming they
had a list of suspects that was getting
shorter by the day eventually they said
they whittled it down to three possible
candidates this wasn't true but
investigators hoped it would make the
killer panic
was this what happened with o'hara was
this why there were no more murders from
then on did he simply
leave everything behind and run away
unfortunately we can't answer any of
those questions because as you probably
already knew
jack the stripper was never identified
like his victorian namesake he became
a mysterious and elusive part of
london's criminal history that being
said
there were a few interesting suspects
worth mentioning the head detective in
charge of the case john du rose
maintained that he knew the identity of
jack the stripper he first dropped this
little bombshell in an interview years
after the last murder
and later repeated it in his memoirs
according to him the police were getting
ready to make an arrest so the killer
committed suicide
after the death of bridget o'hara derose
then refused to name the culprit for the
sake of his living relatives and
referred to him simply
as big john crime author brian mcconnell
dug a little deeper and presented a
little bit more information about the
real jack
in his book he too only named him as big
john but he described him as a man in
his 40s who had a rough upbringing in
scotland full of abuse and beatings
outwardly he presented himself as a
respectable family man with a wife and
kids but he had a habit of using
prostitutes as an outlet for his violent
tendencies
he tried joining the police force but
was rejected so he found work as a
security guard on the heron trading
estate where the last victim was
discovered not everyone was sold on this
idea
during the 70s an investigative reporter
might have inadvertently found an alibi
for big john by
showing that he was in scotland at the
time of one of the murders even later
author david seabrook finally revealed
big john's real name
mungo island even though he believed
that ireland was innocent the latter had
indeed worked for a short period as a
security guard at the estate and
committed suicide in 1965 but seabrook
accused derose
of being corrupt cop who framed a
convenient dead man to close the case
and
end his career on a high note the author
provided an alternative suspect
although he never named him this suspect
was also favored by another officer
working the case
detective superintendent bill baldock
according to them the killer was a
former policeman with a grudge against
scotland yard he had been kicked off the
force after being caught committing
burglaries in the areas he patrolled he
then started killing women in order to
humiliate scotland yard which is why he
dumped each body in a different police
subdivision it sounded plausible but one
thing they could not truly explain
was why he stopped killing these were
probably the two most reasonable
theories but they weren't the only ones
one reformed gangster named jimmy
tippett pointed the finger
at freddie mills the former british
light heavyweight boxing champion one of
england's most popular sporting figures
after the war mel's pursued a career in
entertainment after retirement he
appeared in films television shows and
the radio but also made connections with
london's criminal underworld through
a nightclub that he operated then in
1965 freddie mills was found dead in his
car from a gunshot wound official cause
of death was suicide but since then
numerous stories surrounding his death
have sprung up
tippett claimed that mills killed
himself when he realized that he was
about to be arrested for the murders and
that several people in his inner circle
knew about his dark secret
but would always refuse to go on record
as they weren't the kind of people who
talked cops
the detective who handled mills death
leonard nipper reed
looked into this possibility but found
no evidence for it he claimed that the
confusion arose from the fact that the
chief suspect in the killings had also
been a former boxer who committed
suicide around that time
while that suspect had not been named at
the time we now know
it was mungo island one last hypothesis
to talk about and this one
has been gaining popularity in recent
years is based on the work of
criminologist
david wilson who believed the culprit
could have been a welshman named harold
jones
there was no denying that jones had the
sadistic streak for it in 1921 he was
convicted of killing two young girls
when he was just 15 years old because of
his age
he was spared the death penalty so he
served 20 years in prison before being
released and
allowed to join the army after the war
he moved to london and settled in fulham
under the name
harold stevens some speculate that this
new idea might even cause the case to be
reopened so it is possible that one day
soon
we might find out for certainty the
identity of jack the stripper
so i really hope you found today's video
interesting and if you haven't heard yet
here's a quick reminder that
we're now a few months into my new true
crime podcast the casual criminalist
it's really starting to pick up steam
which is fantastic
thank you everybody there are links to
it below you can subscribe of course on
itunes and spotify and stitcher and
google podcast
all of those places or you could just
watch it on youtube if you fancy that
too there are links
below and thank you for watching
you